la fin du cauchemar pour le liban les
palestiniens seraient évacués dès samedi
des mesures antiterroristes elles ont
été adoptées ce matin au conseil des
ministres la bourse en hausse 3% à paris
une hausse très forte aussi à new york
football scandale à saint-etienne les
joueurs touchés les dessous de table
bonsoir c'est sans doute la fin du
cauchemar pour le liban tout est prêt
maintenant pour l'évacuation des
palestiniens et donc pour le règlement
du conflit
le gouvernement libanais a même annoncé
que l'évacuation allait commencer samedi
ou dimanche et qu'elle devrait s'étaler
sur 15 jours le gouvernement libanais
approuve donc totalement le plan habib
il a convoqué demain les ambassadeurs
français italien et américain pour leur
demander officiellement l'envoi de la
force internationale d'interposition
cette force comprendra deux mille hommes
auxquels s'ajouteront trois mille
soldats de l'armée libanaise
le premier ministre libanais dit
qu'israël a donné son accord sur
l'ensemble de ces points
mais israël ne donnera sa réponse
officielle que demain après une réunion
de cabinet à jérusalem
jean-marc il ouvre favorables qu'ils ont
pu rencontrer chez une partie seulement
d'opinions travailliste les propos de
monsieur mitterrand n'ont guère permis
de dissiper la méfiance du gouvernement
israélien vis-à-vis de la politique
française
hier soir dès la diffusion à la
télévision israélienne de larges
extraits des propos de françois
mitterrand le premier ministre israélien
a immédiatement donné le temps je suis
choqué de voir notre ami françois
mitterrand données sans réserve à l'ol
paie le droit de combattre a fait savoir
messieurs béguines une manière de faire
comprendre avant même que le ministère
des affaires étrangères ne dispose de la
traduction officielle des propos du
président français de faire comprendre
que toute allusion à un rôle politique
de l'olp et reste aujourd'hui comme
après le discours de la knesset reste
une allusion sacrilège pour le
gouvernement israélien
il ne s'est trouvé en tout cas
aujourd'hui aucun haut fonctionnaire
israélien pour venir évoquer sur antenne
la politique du gouvernement israélien
je crois qu'on
toutefois que le ministre des affaires
étrangères regrettent l'absence de
changement de la politique de monsieur
mitterrand
bien sûr la france ne reconnaît pas l'ol
paie mais ici on considère qu elle la
soutient par ailleurs monsieur begin et
monsieur shamir le ministre des affaires
étrangères ont tous deux de nouveau
aujourd'hui encourager les juifs
français à organiser leur propre défense
en cas de défaillance de la police
française
ainsi donc après 165 jours de
négociation ininterrompue et
d'affrontements meurtriers le médiateur
américain philip habib est parvenu à
mettre au point un plan de règlement du
conflit sur place à beyrouth même à part
quelques accrochages sporadiques il n'y
a pas eu de véritable affrontement
depuis six jours maintenant et beyrouth
pense à l'élection présidentielle qui
doit avoir lieu demain c'est le
parlement qui doit choisir un nouveau
chef pour l'état libanais pour six ans
de beyrouth
le témoignage de philippe gassot
entrepris de rendre les inventions
praticable en vue de l'élection
présidentielle qui pourrait avoir lieu
demain
toute la matinée des galions et des
engins aux avancées de la terre va se
remplir les trous du cul car la vie de
l'amour situé au milieu du passage entre
l'est et l'ouest
et c'est depuis les bombardements du 4
août exactement au milieu du gentil sur
lequel est vrai les indés palestino
progressivement durant une semaine et
pse débuté quelques mètres nourris au
prix de combats très durs qui ont
transformé la route de l'hippodrome et
des environnements en ruine au milieu
desquels le lieu de réunion des députés
libanais figure de rescapé d'ailleurs
reçu le don qu'a trouvé de bombe dans le
jardin à l'endroit est transmis au
président de la ftq libanaise dit le
coran et réunit demain ce qui pour le
moment est loin d'être certain volonté
politique de la part des députés entité
bayel et aussi pour démontrer curité
parler demain de sérénité pour les
députés qui viendront dans ce no man's
land prendre une décision qui peut
embraser tout bureaux dans quelques
piques
deuxième titre de l'actualité la lutte
contre le terrorisme en france avec
d'abord cette information que dont je
prends connaissance à l'instant le
commando de la rue des rosiers
comprenait au moins quatre hommes c'est
ce qu'a indiqué ce soir là porritt la
police le commando terroriste qui avait
commis l'attentât antisémite de la rue
des rosiers un attentat qui je vous le
rappelle a fait en dix morts et 22
blessés étaient fort d'au moins quatre
hommes et ce soir leur portrait drobo va
être diffusée par la police sur
l'ensemble du territoire français ce
matin au conseil des ministres le
conseil a approuvé toute une série de
mesures dévoilées pour l'essentiel par
le chef de l'état hier soir dans son
intervention télévisée
toute une série importante de mesure sur
laquelle nous allons revenir plus la
dissolution du groupe action directe
ce mouvement clandestin qui avait
revendiqué les attentats des attentats
et qui étaient en contact avec des
terroristes étrangers
enfin le conseil des ministres a
confirmé la nomination de joseph
française qui comme secrétaire d'état à
la sécurité publique
il était auparavant secrétaire d'état
aux personnes âgées monsieur française
qui devient donc l'homme clé de la lutte
contre le terrorisme
ce n'est pas un hasard s'il a été choisi
il a toujours eu la réputation d'une
grande fermeté
pierre fock un homme à poigne sûrement
on se souvient encore de sa visite à
l'hospice de nanterre le 4 août 1980
joseph franche et ce qu'ils avaient
alors enfermé le directeur dans un
cachot où l'on mettait les petits vieux
dont la conduite n'était pas
satisfaisant lors de ses visites
surprises de tout nouveau secrétaire
d'état aux personnes âgées avaient
dénoncé les conditions de vie
lamentables des vieillards dans ses
auspices qu'il avait qualifié de mouroir
d'après son entourage l'homme est
passionné et assez autoritaire il c'est
obtenir des gens ce qu'il veut dans les
rapports professionnels
c'est également un homme de contact
alfortville ville dont il est maire
depuis 1965 il n'hésite pas à recevoir
les gens personnellement dans son bureau
c'est très tôt que cet homme de 58 ans
né à tunis dans une famille corse s'est
intéressé à la politique puisque à l'âge
de 14 ans il s'est inscrit aux jeunesses
socialistes
licencié en lettres et docteur en droit
il devient député de la 4e
circonscription du val de marne en 1973
et sera depuis constamment réélu
joseph française qui est un vieil ami de
françois mitterrand chargé en 1974 de
préparer ses meetings et en 1981 de
s'occuper de la sécurité du candidat
socialiste
sachez enfin qu'il fut vice président de
l'assemblée nationale en 77 et 78 ce
palmarès et les résultats de son action
auprès des personnes âgées lui auront
donc valu le poste difficile de monsieur
sécurité en france
une précision le secrétariat d'état aux
personnes âgées est maintenue pour
l'instant c'est georgina dufoix qui
chargeaient des problèmes de la famille
qui va en assurer l'intérim jusqu'à la
désignation d'un nouveau titulaire
nous avons donc maintenant qu'on mesure
est le même c'est gaston defferre qui
les a présenté ce matin au conseil des
ministres lui 6e bull les détails mise
en service d'un fichier central
antiterroriste informatisé ce fichier a
été créé le 24 mai dernier sa mise en
fonctionnement sera accélérée il doit
être opérationnel début octobre
création d'un office central pour la
répression du trafic d armes et d
explosifs
la vente de certaines armes sera
désormais interdite aux frontières le
contrôle des visas et des papiers
d'identité deviendra beaucoup plus
strictes dans ce sens pour assurer une
meilleure surveillance des frontières
les effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie vont être renforcés seront
mis en place
7000 agents supplémentaires pour la
police elles mêmes et 2000 agents pour
la gendarmerie de plus 1400 agents iront
grossir les rangs de la paf la police de
l'air et des frontières
il existe aujourd'hui 12 brigades
mobiles
elles seront
33 au 1er octobre françois mitterrand a
précisé qu'il en faudrait encore une
vingtaine de plus dans les mois à venir
dernière mesure annoncée des
détachements de gendarmerie auxiliaires
viendront relayer les gardiens de la
paix chargé de la surveillance des
immeubles publics des ambassades et des
consulats
enfin le gouvernement entend surveiller
les abus commis par certaines ambassades
qui font entrer des armes en france
grâce aux facilités diplomatique la
france proposera également la création
d'un tribunal européen qui sera en
mesure de juger les auteurs d'actions
terroristes et les crimes de sang enfin
toute organisation instaurant la
violence en système sera poursuivie est
interdite
je vous parlais tout à l'heure de la
nomination d'un secrétaire d'état à la
sécurité publique josé franceschi il y a
aussi un deuxième homme clé dans cette
lutte contre le terrorisme il s'agit de
christian prouteau chef d'escadron à la
gendarmerie nationale il est chargé
d'une mission de coordination
d'information et d'action contre le
terrorisme
monsieur anti terrorisme en quelque
sorte ils étaient déjà une sorte de
gendarme de choc puisque c'est lui qui
dirigeait depuis 73 le gign l'unité
d'élite de l'inde à la gendarmerie
pardon chargé des opérations délicates
on pourrait parler de christian prouteau
comme d'un super gendarmes il a 38 ans
et dirige le gign le groupe
d'intervention de la gendarmerie
nationale depuis sa création en 74
cette unité d'élite composée de soixante
gendarmes intervient toujours sur des
missions délicates terrorisme forcené ou
grand banditisme en 1976 à djibouti
c'était pour la libération de 30 enfants
prise en otage par le front de
libération de la côte française des
somalis que le gign est intervenu
sous les ordres de christian prouteau
une petite fille est morte
malheureusement mais les autres enfants
ont pu être délivrés
en 1978 le groupe d'intervention de la
gendarmerie nationale intervenait sur la
mutinerie des prisonniers de la centrale
de clairvaux mission on ne peut plus
délicate également puisque deux détenus
étaient armés à l'intérieur de la prison
enfin 79 une équipe du gign pars en
arabie saoudite prêter main forte aux
forces de l'ordre saoudiennes pour
déloger les musulmans intégristes qui
occupaient la grande mosquée de la
mecque 1980 à ajaccio des nationalistes
corses ont investi l'hôtel flèche et six
barricades en prenant des clients en
otage il ne semble pas déterminé à tuer
mais pendant que ses hommes sont en
place christian prouteau négocié et
obtient la reddition des autonomistes en
douceur 1980 toujours fort chabrol en
gironde à pauillac christian prouteau
est blessé au visage par le tir du
forcené
une carrière qui n'a pas été de tout
repos si l'on en juge par l'entraînement
intensif des super gendarme du gign mais
depuis deux mois le commandant prouteau
était aussi chargé d'étudier la sécurité
du palais de l'elysée voilà que son
champ d'action s'étend à tout le
terrorisme la nomination de christian
poteau risque quand même de créer un
petit problème
tous les policiers ne sont pas
particulièrement ravis qu'un commandant
de gendarmerie a été désigné pour
coordonner les actions des services de
la police nationale et de la gendarmerie
bien sûr les syndicats sont plutôt
satisfait de l'ensemble des mesures
annoncées
mais la nomination de monsieur prouteau
leur reste en travers de la gorge
exemple la cftc qui n'est pas contente
du tout autre exemple eh bien écoutez ce
témoignage d'un représentant de l'un des
syndicats des inspecteurs la gendarmerie
a été privilégié pendant de nombreuses
années par rapport à la police nationale
il est bien évident que la gendarmerie
est bénéficiaire a été a eu des moyens
et des effectifs
nous constatons la nomination de
monsieur proto comme chargé de mission
j'aurais tout de suite dire que pour
nous il s'agit d'un désaveu pour les la
haute hiérarchie de notre ministère
je voudrais dire que notre organisation
syndicale n'est pas contre 7 la
hiérarchie mais que nous sommes contre
la hiérarchie qui n'assure qu'il
n'assume pas ses responsabilités et vous
pensez pas que c'est du corporatisme pas
du tout ce n'est pas du corporatisme pas
vouloir un militaire à la tête de cette
mission
écoutez je ne mets pas en cause de
capacité de monsieur courteau je dis
simplement que nous aurions préféré
qu'il s'agisse d'un policier ayant enfin
la lutte contre le terrorisme à
l'échelon européen
dans les mesures approuvées par le
gouvernement il y à la proposition d'un
tribunal européen pour juger des
extraditions meilleur françois
mitterrand avait lancé une idée encore
plus large celle d'un tribunal européen
en mesure de juger aussi les crimes de
sang
la création d'un tel tribunal
impliquerait un abandon de souveraineté
au niveau du pouvoir judiciaire et
relancerait d'une certaine manière le
problème de la supra nationaux simon de
ce tribunal européen
ça pousse tellement de problèmes que
2 les résume le problème du corpus pena
sur la base duquel il pourrait statuer
le problème de la saisine qu'il
saisirait est ce qu'il pourrait se
saisir lui-même le problème des conflits
de compétences avec les autres tribunaux
je dire ça suppose en effet il ya un
implicite pour qu'aboutisse un tribunal
comme ça d'intégration européenne et de
deux supranationalité accentué bon le
est ce que les états membres la
communauté européenne sont prêts à faire
ce pas politique pour arriver à ce
résultat juridique ça pour l'instant ça
n'est pas évident est ce que c'est bien
réaliste est-ce que c'est réaliste
d'inventer un tribunal comme ça oui et
non on peut imaginer comme ça un peu en
plus on a essayé de penser ce que serait
ce tribunal
il aurait les avantages incontestables
d'une grande publicité et qui dit
publicité des débats
10 garantie de bruges styliste de
sérénité enfin bon c'est une des
garanties de bonne justice
ça serait peut-être comme ça idéalement
une bonne chose mais encore une fois
comment le réaliser ou c'est irréaliste
c'est dans le contexte institutionnel
actuel c'est 13 ans rendent en un bond
en avant de l'état institutionnel de
l'europe pour que ça puisse me semble
dans ce premier examen pour que ça
puisse aboutir rapidement
pour finir avec cet important chapitre
il faut revenir sur l'intervention de
françois mitterrand hier et ses
conséquences politiques alors philippe
harrouard est ce qu on a pu noter hier
un changement de ton c'est à dire le
style de françois mitterrand eh bien
peut-être écouté d'une part le chef de
l'état indique qu'il n'aime pas parler
tout le temps pour ne pas user la
fonction d'autre part monsieur
mitterrand précise qu'il doit expliquer
lui-même les aspects majeurs de la
politique française il ne dis pas
d'ailleurs quels sont les aspects
majeurs mais à l'écouter hier on avait
l'impression que quelque chose avait
changé dans sa façon d'agir
il s'est mis à découvert seul sans
jamais associé dans ses propos le
premier ministre ou le gouvernement il a
pris des décisions rapides inhabituelles
comme la nomination d'un secrétaire
d'état à la sécurité dans l'heure qui
vient
on comprend évidemment que les
événements lui ont poussé et le chef de
l'état a dit encore qu'il re parlerai
aux français dans quelques temps sur
d'autres sujets alors on se découvrant
ainsi monsieur mitterrand prend des
risques le risque de se voir critiquer
directement en général sous la vème
république le premier ministre sert de
rempart de fusible face à la gestion
quotidienne du pays
c'était la règle l'habitude mais
monsieur mitterrand faisait remarquer
aux journalistes qui l'interrogeaient
après tout connaissez-vous mes habitudes
alors en se réservant le droit de parler
quand il le juge opportun utile monsieur
mitterrand a l'air d'effacer la règle et
c'est peut-être ça qui est nouveau les
autres décisions du conseil des
ministres ce matin maintenant la
création d'abord de deux nouvelles
pièces de monnaie l'une 200 francs en
argent représentant le panthéon l'autre
de 10 francs métal courant à l'éffigie
de gambetta
le conseil a d'autre part mis en oeuvre
un fonds spécial pour les grands travaux
il s'agit de soutenir la croissance et
l'emploi notamment dans le secteur du
bâtiment et des travaux publics 11
milliards de travaux nouveau lancé à
partir de septembre au conseil encore le
président de la république a exprimé sa
satisfaction devant les indices
enregistré en juillet 0 3% de hausse
pour les prix et un chiffre du chômage
qui se stabilise
conséquence la bourse a immédiatement
bien réagi à ces bons résultats ainsi
d'ailleurs qu'au discours de françois
mitterrand il y a eu 3 % de hausse pour
les valeurs françaises ce matin à paris
il faut dire aussi que cette hausse est
provoquée par des facteurs
internationaux
aussi hier à wall street par exemple la
bourse de new york à la bourse de new
york l'indicé dow jones avait flambé en
une seule séance
une séance exceptionnelle comme il n'en
arrive que très rarement 38 points de
hausse en une seule fois la hausse de
wall street a donc lu ce matin des
répercussions à paris de même le dollar
lui est allé en sens inverse c'est
normal il est descendu de 12 centimes il
à côté exactement 6 francs 89 à paris
contre 7 francs 0 1 la veille alors
qu'il s'assied cette bourse à new york a
des conséquences tout à fait précise au
fait oui il faut dire hervé que wall
street est dans la finance
internationale ce qu'une cathédrale et à
une chapelle de caen
pas chaque jour il s'échange à la bourse
de new york
plus d'action que pendant tout un mois à
paris et la valeur de toutes les actions
cotées à wall street et bien représente
environ huit fois le budget d'un pays
comme la france c'est vous dire alors
les mouvements sont à wall street
extrêmement brutaux un petit peu à
l'échelle de l'américain général une
forte hausse anticipe sur une reprise de
l'économie américaine qui actuellement
est malade à la fois de l'inflation du
chômage et des faillites d'entreprises
mais rien ne permet d'affirmer que cette
reprise sera bien au rendez vous dans
six mois alors la flambée d'hier
philippe s'explique surtout par la
baisse des taux d'intérêt américains à
laquelle les américains semblent croire
maintenant oui il faut dire que henri
kaufman qui est un des grands oracle
financier à wall street a annoncé qu'il
croyait bien à une baisse persistante de
ses taux d'intérêt plus ou moins
intéressants de détenir des dollars
parce qu'ils sont moins rémunérés ce qui
explique que la monnaie américaine est
en train de baisser un petit peu partout
et a contrario il paraît plus avantageux
d'acheter des actions ces tombeaux à peu
près le jeu de bascule qui est en train
de se produire mais il faut noter qu
henri kaufman pour réputé qu'il soit
s'est déjà trompé et qu'il ya une
semaine il disait exactement l inverse
de ce qu il a dit aujourd'hui bref
filles aussi quelque chose d'assez
inquiétant avoir une flambée aussi
spectaculaire déclenchée par une simple
prévisions en tout cas la bourse de
paris a suivi aujourd'hui à la bourse de
paris a suivi parce qu'effectivement
wall street donne le la à l'ensemble des
places boursières de toute la planète
mais il ya d'autres raisons hervé vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure d'abord il ya
le bon indice des prix du mois de
juillet qui a réconforté les boursiers
puis il faut dire également que les
propos tenus hier par le chef de l'état
ont fait bonne impression à la bourse de
paris
en général les facteurs psychologiques
sont pratiquement aussi important que
les résultats économiques
le reste de l'actualité internationale
le coup d'état aux seychelles aurait
fait de nombreuses victimes
dès ce matin le gouvernement du
président rené a repris le contrôle de
la situation les soldats rebelles ont
été chassés de la radio et des quelques
points stratégiques qu'ils occupaient
leurs otages ont sans doute ont même
certainement gelé appris il ya quelques
minutes étaient libérés mais je vous le
disais les affrontements ont fait des
victimes
j'ajoute qu'un bâtiment de la flotte
française fait route actuellement vers
les seychelles
en pologne ère nouvelle manifestation du
syndicat solidarité et nouvelles
arrestations aussi vous allez le voir
sur ces images des milliers de tracts
avaient été lancées il va appeler la
population à une grande manifestation
pour le 31 août dans la soirée les
forces de police sont de nouveau
disperser les manifestants brutalement
les quelques centaines de personnes qui
avaient reconstitué place de la victoire
la cua la croix de fleurs à la mémoire
du cardinal dit chinsky une croix que
les autorités font enlever chaque nuit
et je la prends maintenant il y a eu ce
soir une manifestation à stettin
toujours donc en pologne
les ouvriers des chantiers navals barski
de stettin ont interrompu le travail cet
après midi et ils ont manifesté devant
leur entreprise c'est la télévision
polonaise même qui l'a annoncé
haïti un durcissement politique depuis
début août le gouvernement du président
à vie jean claude duvalier a lancé une
vaste opération contre les progressistes
de l'île de nombreuses personnalités ont
été arrêtés c'est le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur lafontan qui mène
en personne la répression le sport
maintenant au plus tôt au l'actualité en
marge du sport avec beaucoup de zones
dont vous allez le voir ce soir
mais commençons par les bonnes choses
didier pironi le coureur automobile
blessés il y a dix jours va beaucoup
mieux qu'il est rentré tout à l'heure en
france après avoir été soigné pendant
dix jours à l'hôpital d'heidelberg en
allemagne un avion sanitaire spécial la
ramener voici son ambulance qui arrivent
nous avons nous n'avons pas voulu filmer
qu'ironique est encore très marqué par
son à son accident mais sa santé
s'améliore le professeur letournel qui
va le soigner l'a expliqué à didier
schoffit notre mieux supporter le voyage
il se plaignait un peu de la tête on m'a
dit je pense que l'excès fracture chez
voyages sont
même s'ils étaient liés même si le
maximum de confort tu tâche de leur
répression
il est impossible de dénombrer les
fractures actuellement il y en a
tellement
d'où il a tout ce qui a été donné où il
dit déjà est exact il ya le bras et des
deux jambes
c'est à dire sur les deux jambes y en a
combien ouais ça me sens bien fracturé
mais le nombre de fragments nous importe
c'est peu de la reconstruction sera
réalisé s'il est possible d'y reprendre
un volant à peu près quand après vous là
vous me posez une question très
difficile le maximum sera fait pour que
didier puisse reprendre un volant
on a parlé du mois de septembre c'est
une benne d'un optimiste surtout petit
miss je pense que non tant à l'actualité
est très sombre du sport français
maintenant avec deux affaires qui
entachent sérieusement le football et le
cyclisme professionnel football d'abord
avec un scandale à saint-etienne ce
matin roger rocher l'ancien président du
club a été entendu par les policiers de
la brigade financière il avait à
s'expliquer sur une caisse noire qui lui
aurait permis de donner des dessous de
table aux joueurs on en parlait depuis
longtemps mais maintenant il n'y a plus
de doute cette caisse noire à exister
les joueurs le disent eux-mêmes
publiquement ecoutez jean françois
larios ce le capitaine des verts
le cd authority de vie que
tous les grands 10 ans de ce club
empêcher cette option culte et seule
chose que je regrette c'est que monsieur
rocher mais lors d'une dernière entrevue
nous avons eu dernièrement à
saint-etienne une semaine affirme
défendre les intérêts des joueurs parce
qu'il adorait ses joueurs je pense que
s'il fait ça bon il a ses raisons
maintenant s'il veut dévoiler le nom des
les joueurs ça ne dérange vraiment pas
parce que vous savez depuis deux mois ou
trois mois
certains joueurs dont je fais partie
nous savons c'est une autorité publique
toute façon nous allons toucher quelque
somme de savoir quand il convient
également glossa je ne peux pas vous
dire parce que je ne sais même pas moi
même mais le problème c'est que moi de
tous ces problèmes là je commence à en
avoir marre
moi je suis footballeur j'avais de jouer
au football je préfère qu'on règle tous
ces problèmes un et qu'on nous laisse
tranquille et que l'on fasse
correctement leur métier
ça nous met à l'interné dirigeants alors
je vais belle comment fonctionnait cette
casse noix à saint-etienne vient je
croyais avec il faut tout d'abord savoir
que roger rocher en sortant du srpj de
lyon cet après midi a confirmé qu'il
avait bien tout dit à la brigade
financière et notamment les noms des
joueurs qui avaient touché des dessous
de table alors en ce qui concerne cette
caisse noire il est difficile de savoir
puisque monsieur roger rocher a refusé
d'expliquer comment elle était alimentée
notamment à la nouvelle équipe
dirigeante de saint-etienne et comment
il avait accumulé ces 300 millions de
centimes dans ce bas de laine il semble
d'après m fj et loue le nouveau
président de l'as saint-etienne que le
système de la double billetterie soit à
exclure dans ce cas reste plusieurs
manières de remplir ce bas de laine
d'abord les buvettes
mais ce n'est pas en dissimulant une
partie des recettes des buvettes que
l'on arrive à mettre de côté 3 millions
de francs li également les recettes des
matches amicaux un peu plus facile a
trafiqué
mais surtout la formule qui consiste à
déclarer un plus grand nombre d'abonnés
de gens qui prennent des cartes à
l'année et de vendre des billets pour
remplir les places vides laissés par ses
abonnés factice ce qui revient à une
forme de double billetterie
mais tout cela n'est pour l'instant que
supposition
vous-même roger on peut imaginer que
saint-etienne est pas le seul dans ce
cas ce que la pratique des caisses
noires est courante dans les clubs de
football français il ya deux précédents
dans l'histoire des caisses noires
d'abord marseille en 1972 où marcel
leclerc le président de l'époque a dû
s'expliquer sur un bas de laine de 3
millions de francs et puis en 1978 cette
fameuse affaire de la double billetterie
de paris saint germain alors est-ce
pratique courante on peut effectivement
se poser la question mais rien ne permet
de l'affirmer pour l'instant
généralement les caisses noires sont
découvertes lorsqu'il ya une crise dans
l'équipe dirigeante nakhle dernière
question très rapidement rejet lario sa
lâcher le morceau on peut le dire alors
qu'est ce qu'il risque devient
jean-françois larios hausse mais
également les joueurs les mieux payés
on pense entre autres à michel platini
johnny rep rocher dont roger rocher a dû
révéler les noms au srpj ses joueurs
devront payer normalement un
redressement fiscal ils seront entendus
par le srpj de lyon
de plus si les instances les hautes
instances du football français
respectent le règlement
eh bien ces joueurs sont également
passibles de sanctions au niveau fédéral
au niveau fédéral par bon pour avoir
touché ces dessous de table après les
soutes table de pages cette fois ce
n'est plus de football c'est pour le
cyclisme c'est la suite de la sphère du
critérium de callac ou cinq coureurs
dont hinault ont refusé le contrôle
antidopage et ont été sanctionnés par la
fédération alors ce soir les coureurs
réagissent ils menacent de boycotter le
championnat du monde
et pour commencer le tour du limousin
dont le départ est prévu jeudi ce soir
donc les coureurs bernard hinault en
tête sont réunis à limoges alors alain
vernon vous êtes là bas est ce qu'une
décision a été prise et bien toujours
pas hervé au moment où je vous parle les
coureurs sous la présidence d'andré
chalmel
bernard hinault et là aussi ils sont
toujours en réunion dans les locaux du
comité du limousin de la fédération
française de cyclisme
il n'y a donc pas de décision prise pour
l'instant pour 23 heures je pourrais
bien sûr vous en parlait en tout cas
selon jean rené bernaudeau cet après
midi qui a gagné hier le le critérium de
quillan où curieusement le deuxième
contrôle antidopage n'a pas lieu donc
pour jean rené bernaudeau
il n'est pas question et ont
vraisemblablement de boycotter le 15e
tour de limousin qui prendra son départ
demain ici aile gauche et pour les
championnats du monde et bien bernard
vallet lui-même nous confier que
vraisemblablement l'ensemble des
coureurs ne songez pas réellement à ce
boycott en tout cas dans cette affaire
de quels acquis à des prolongements
regrettable un peu avant les
championnats du monde et bien la
fédération et les coureurs sans faute
ils tous les deux les coureurs parce que
bien sûr ils ont désobéi au règlement en
quelque sorte
et puis bien sûr ils n'ont pas à se
doper le savent et puis d'autre part
surtout la fédération française avait
prévu ce contrôle antidopage dès le mois
de mars 82 c'est monsieur simon le
président de la fédération française qui
me l'a confié au téléphone
donc les coureurs auraient pu éviter ce
conflit bien avant et puis la fédération
de son côté est coupable elle aussi
parce que quand des coureurs viennent de
terminer le tour de france et qu'il
parte pour un critérium dès le lendemain
alors qu'il se sent coucher très tard
dans la nuit
et bien c'est tout simplement de
l'hypocrisie pour ne pas dire du vice
que d'imposer un contrôle antidopage en
tout cas je vous tiendrai au courant
dans le journal de 23 heures de cette
affaire les coureurs sont toujours
réunies je vous le disais dans les
locaux du comité régional du limousin
pour décider du boycott ou pas du tout
de l'image du champion du monde mais
vraisemblablement on partira demain ici
à limoges et on fera le champion du
monde ce que l'on veut c'est que la
fédération française revienne sur sa
décision quelques sortes le syndicalisme
du cycle inside de faire pression on
nous remercie alain il y un kart et
demain il se court à vincennes voici les
pronostics de pierrette brès je vous
laisse noter je vous rappelle les
numéros qu'elle vous propose le 11 le
dise le 14 le 7 le 15 le 9 et le 5
voilà laurent broomhead maintenant les
prévisions de la météo pour de masquer
ses meilleures qu'hier
bah écoute et malheureusement hervé je
dois vous annoncer quelques nuages en
plus c'est la faute aux deux satellites
va tout nous expliquer regarde ont été
prises à 17h par meteosat
l'infrarouge regardez bien cette bande
de nuages qui sépare de l'air chaud et
de leurs froisser la rencontre des deux
qui fait les nuages les nuages étaient
donc à 17h sur le nord ouest du pays où
elle l'espagne hitler italie aussi le
sud et dans la nuit vont se décaler
comme ceux ci à peu près alors sur le
sud il fera encore chaud mais nous
aurons une chute de température derrière
puisque l'air qui lie actuellement ici
et qui va arriver sur la france est plus
frais c'est extrêmement simple on va
voir maintenant la carte pour demain et
on va découvrir donc cette bande de
nuages situer le matin de l'atlantique
au nord-est et qui va se décaler vers le
sud est dans la journée on la retrouve
vers midi ici voyez des pyrénées au
massif central jusqu'au nord des alpes
pas beaucoup de pluie mais disons un
temps humide avec quelques orages en
particulier en montagne et quelques
averses et quelques plus passagers à des
bruines sur la méditerranée bien il fera
toujours chaud mais il y aura de plus en
plus de nuages al'approche donc de cette
zone de pluie qui arrivera le soir sur
les pyrénées et le languedoc ainsi que
les alpes avec des risques d'orages plus
au nord
instauration d'un temps variable comme
on dit alors du sud de la bretagne au
centre ce sera assez bien il y aura du
soleil et puis simplement quelques
passages nuageux mais plus au nord c'est
un temps beaucoup plus nuageux avec des
éclaircies c'est vrai mais des gros
passages de gros nuages sombres et en
corse les averses possibles sur les
frontières est principalement près des
courts du côté des températures
maintenant et bien un chute 17 18 degrés
sur le nord ouest puis de 3 4 degrés
dans toutes ces régions toujours 29 30
degrés sur l'extrême sud est ont terminé
notre agenda et je conclurai en vous
disant que vendredi il y aura un peu
moins de nuages mais les températures
toujours inférieures aux normales
saisonnières
merci laurent voilà le ce journal est
terminée le prochain rendez vous avec
l'information c'est jacques merino ce
soir vers 23h15 ensuite demain matin
antennes de midi présenté par christian
bonneau
christian mary mono 12h45 pour ma part
je vous retrouverai à 20h avec plaisir
mon sort